what's going on reject nation it's Greg
Alba here so today I'm gonna do what I
did for Justice League which is give you
guys my thoughts on the second time I
watched this movie first time I watched
it was a few days before the movie
actually had its theatrical release it
was at a Disney press screening which is
really cool to go to and it was just
regular 2d format and then the second
time I watched it was on the Sunday came
out and that was on IMAX 3d and both
viewing experiences definitely had its
differences when I saw it at the press
screening I was just in love with the
movie and I didn't hear any of the
common complaints that people have been
having about the film that Star Wars
fans have been feeling about it some
stuff I thought maybe they'll have
issues with it but there's other things
that I was like I wasn't expecting
people to be so taken aback by this I've
heard plenty of spoiler talks on this so
I can see what the common complaints
have been about the film and then when I
go to watch the movie the second time
I'm aware of all this stuff in my mind
as I'm watching it I could say some
stuff I agree with there's some stuff
though that I'm like nah I you know I I
don't feel that way about it I figured I
could go a little bit more in depth
because Grant we had a spoiler talk this
will be a little bit more concise and
much more specific on the main issues at
the film who's been receiving complaints
about so before going into that I want
to first say the IMAX experience it was
pretty cool watching this movie in that
format with the sound design and the
imagery was beautiful however the 3d
sucked I've heard some people say the
IMAX 3d is really cool that the 3ds pop
in and I watched it now I don't I don't
remember one time I was like wow those
images are popping out the only time I
remember it popping out is when there's
trailers playing before the movie where
it says the following preview has been
approved for all audiences and that's
like coming at you that's the only thing
that really popped out at me the the
rest of the 3d I could have done with
that and in fact even though I like
watching it on a huge screen like
something like IMAX I wish it wasn't in
3d because I don't like that color tint
that it does it makes the whole movie
look a lot darker than it actually is
it's especially not satisfying when
noting in 3d is even really happening so
there's six main things I mainly want to
cover gonna start off small and then
you know we're getting to the big
spoiler talks seen on the last hour of
this movie a lot later the first things
the humor the first time I watched this
movie I thought it was really funny
actually a lot of the humorous moments
hit for me there actually wasn't a
humorous moment that didn't work for me
when I first watched it the second time
I watched it was an interesting
experience because it's a packed theater
still but there were jokes that people
cracked up at the first time I watched
it and then the second time I watched it
there were jokes that I still laughed
that that nobody was laughing at it and
there were jokes were just nobody was
laughing one of the jokes that's
something that doesn't fly too well with
a lot of people is when Luke throws the
lightsaber away I personally loved that
moment I do I get that if you don't like
that moment that seems like they're just
going for a comedic moment or might seem
a little bit out of line for who Luke is
but in that moment I thought it was a
great surprise because there's all this
hype and build-up to that scene in the
force awakens when you finally get to
Luke and she's holding the lightsaber
you watch trailer so the last Jedi
before shredders come out you're
speculating how this film might go down
and then when you watch the movie these
cats are really putting on a show right
now and then when you watch the movie
and Luke throws a lightsaber it's so
unexpected that and for me personally I
couldn't help but laugh at that moment
there are some comedic moments that seem
a little out of place but still made me
laugh regardless that scene when Pato is
talking with general Hux at the
beginning he's making the joke about
being on hold waiting for general Hux
that's one of those moments where it
still fits for the character of Poe but
the way the dialogue was written was
written like comedy dialogue and that's
why I could feel like it's a little off
because Poe joking around like that
doesn't seem off to me what seemed off
was the writing of the jokes because the
jokes felt like comedy lines instead of
just sounding like natural lines the
characters might say if anything the
times in the comedy scene offer a little
lackluster to me was stuff with Finn
Finn does that look the hmm that's weird
like when bb-8 is manning that one
machine and I forget the name off my top
of my head right now but then bb-8 and
then one machine on the lookee goes bb-8
that punch line of that stare can only
go so far but the rest of the humor I
really don't mind I know what you guys
really want to hear about our specifics
though right the specific stuff one
thing I loved and I thought was very
effective even the second time I watched
was the scene when you think Leia dodge
the ship blows up and that she goes out
in his face and then suddenly she's
honing in on the force it's the first
time we're really seeing lay I used the
force and she's Superman's her way back
to the ships and Superman but she you
know she flies her way back to the ship
or some I saw that scene I really loved
it but as the film kept progressing I
kept asking myself what the hell was she
doing here I mean how did she survive
this to begin with what exactly is she
doing is the force make a human being
capable of breathing or surviving in
space as I'm pretty sure it's an instant
death when you're in space but the
second time I watched it I feel like the
one justification I could give it
because I don't know the full rules of
how the force works it seems like this
movie is taking the time out to reinvent
or make additions to how the force
operates but the scene when she's having
that cutting back and forth between kylo
and Leia before the part of the ship
blows up she does take this moment of
acceptance where she closes her eyes or
she looks down one of the two the second
time I watched it this could just be
mean to be justifying the situation I
felt like she was sort of creating some
forcefield that we can't see but she's
creating some force field around her
where you know the force field is being
penetrated so she's still kind of
becoming frozen but it's happening so
slowly that to me it seems like that she
was honing in on the force before she
got to space was the first time I
watched it it plays out like she's in
space and then she starts thinking about
honing in on the force I think as the
ship was blowing up she concentrated and
was able to hone in on the force
capabilities before she started floating
out into space that could just be a
justification on my end I would have
liked a little bit of an explanation
I would have liked some of the
characters to have least said a line of
how was she doing that how was she able
to do that what is she doing you know
something like that but the movies are a
two-and-a-half-hour so I'm sure they
just trimmed it out the main issue that
I had the first time I watched this and
it I felt even stronger about it was
specifically Finn's storyline I did feel
like they were looking for something for
Finn to do in this movie and after
watching it a second time I actually had
more thoughts and questions about Finn's
storyline because there's a storyline
with Finn Rosa intertwines would pose
storyline people having a lot of
complaints about it saying it's all
unnecessary when they go to that Las
Vegas like planet that the whole story
life you
unnecessary that Benicio Del Toro's
character DJ feels unnecessary too I
don't agree with that entirely on both
points I do feel that Finn's storyline
when they go to that planet drags on way
too long I feel like we could have spent
less time there probably that storyline
specifically is that the themes and
messages of that storyline are more
powerful than the plot of the storyline
itself because this is Star Wars I like
the idea of exploring life style in the
galaxy and this war has been going on
forever it was cool to see the world and
have the question answered of where did
people get all these weapons and
machinery to keep fighting this war
who's supplying the first order and
who's supplying the resistance and that
was neat to have DJ's character
introduced that element that represents
real life war in a lot more ways than
one the whole storyline with those
animals that break out and you know
harming animals animal abuse is wrong
those are powerful points these are
powerful messages they're making the
thing is the themes and messages seem a
lot more impactful than the actual plot
of it when they're in that Las Vegas
casino like place that goes on for way
too long I'm still confused on the DJ
storyline was he supposed to be put into
jail with them this film seems to be
toying with the idea that it's not all
about fate and destiny yet this other
coder happened to be in the same jail
cell that Finn and Rose were and he's
not like DJ being there is because of
the fact if it wasn't for them getting
the coder if it wasn't for Finn
Rose and Poe going behind their leaders
backs and trying to take care of this
mission themselves a lot of the
resistance wouldn't have gotten killed
because once DJ starts working with the
first order the rebel ships that are
escaping they get targeted on and then a
lot of the resistance gets obliterated
and that's because Finn and Rose and Poe
they messed up they shouldn't have done
that
that's why I like that storyline I like
the idea of subverting expectations you
think this plan will just go the way
they want or they might have a few
hiccups along the way but in the end
they'll succeed so that's one reason why
I like it the other reason is because of
that I think it adds effect to Poe's
storyline him learning to not just be a
hotshot to not just always fight or try
to take things into his own hands he's
really learning to be a leader
but then there's problems with that as
well something that I noticed the second
time I watched it why does hold oh never
tell PO that they have a plan all PO
wants to hear is they actually have a
legit plan it doesn't seem like the kind
of plan that not everyone needs to hear
idea that we all get an escape pause and
go to another planet the resistance has
been shrunken by a lot since the opening
battle of this movie the resistance is a
lot smaller what harm does it do if
everyone here's the plan like more than
just PO if everyone here's the plan I
think in this survival situation when a
giant ship is attacking your smaller
ship you're counting on the last
remaining fuel and the last bit of
shield power you have I think everyone
on your ship that's being attacked needs
to have a sense of security and it needs
to have a sense of hope I didn't
understand why she kept it from PO or
why she kept it from the entire
resistance that's where I feel like fin
storyline begins to feel unnecessary
because all that could have been
prevented as long as hold though just
told him what the plan was cuz once PO
found out what the plan is from Leia
when he's already been knocked out and
he's on that ship going to the planet he
just has a response like oh that's a
good plan needed to happen as long as Bo
just got the word a long time ago and
the problem of that is there was no
reason to keep it from it the other part
DJ storyline of why I liked his
inclusion in there again is because if
it wasn't for DJ the whole plan wouldn't
have gone away and a lot of people
wouldn't have gotten killed in the
resistance that's Finn's fall for
recruiting DJ the issue of that of why I
think no one's really walking away with
that feeling the second time I watched
it I started thinking maybe I'm
justifying that I like that but the
thing is the movie doesn't seem to
acknowledge that that's the issue the DJ
storyline would have been more effective
if there was just one line or two from
Finn and Rose where when the resistance
is getting obliterated where they have
one scene where they say out loud to
each other or to someone maybe even Poe
if it wasn't for us there would be a lot
more of the resistance still alive it's
our fault that would have been powerful
enough and I think it would have made
that moment more powerful when Finn is
going to crash into that Laserbeak
there's going
sacrifice himself that would have been a
lot more powerful and more of a rooting
for redemption moment if it was made
clear to the audience that he feels
responsible for why a lot of the
resistance has been diminished I mean
this stuff would phasma I briefly
touched on the nos war talk a lot about
it and spoiler talk some phasma is very
lackluster it's cooler than the force
awakens I don't really feel like getting
into it again
that's one big fault of it because
there's so much set up that this is
gonna allow me to transition into the
main big ones that people seem very
upset about which is snoke's death and
Rey's parents a lot of this seems to be
coming from the community of people who
are obsessed with fan theories the
reason why I never really harped on fan
theories or why snoke's death or the
reveal of Rey's parents being nobody
really bothered me is because of one
major reason I know how JJ Abrams is
right we've seen a lot of JJ Abrams work
he's the master at setting up an
intriguing ass mystery box he's great at
setting up a mystery box the thing is a
lot of times when JJ writes those things
into his storylines he doesn't even know
the answer to the mystery box that's why
loss was disappointing think about how I
produced Cloverfield or directing super8
those films I have this mystery box to
it then when you watch those two films
you realize the only mystery to be
solved is what is the monster look like
that's about as far as it goes it's just
what does the monster look like that's
it there's no answers there who the
monster is and they even direct him am i
three and there there's this whole
mystery box two of the thing Tom Cruise
needs to find you never find out what's
in the box rabbit's foot what is it
promise me you'll stay I'll tell you
Sydnee postcard ryan johnson made it
very clear that when he took up the task
of the last Jedi that they had no
answers for snow they didn't know who
Snoke was and if you look back at the
force awakens Snoke is written like a
very cliche villain who's just a
hologram there's nothing special about
Snoke it's I think it was the fan
theories that really made Snoke
SuperDuper special would he have been
significant of course and same thing
will Ray's parents though JJ doesn't
know who Ray's parents are so Ryan
Johnson is tasked with this impossible
thing of filling in the blanks and try
to satisfy everyone and the other thing
that happens too is if any of the fan
theories came true the reveal of Snoke
who Ray's parents are if any of those
fan theories came true then it would
have been like Oh Star Wars is
predictable because people were able to
guess it it's pretty predictable now
that's just a backlash that tends to
happen and I'm sorry for the people that
got really hurt by fan theories not
getting answered or getting answers that
you want but the truth is there's people
who were coming up with fan theories
when none of it was true and none of it
mattered because the person who created
the questions didn't even know the
answers so you could theorize all day
but unless the person who created it
knows the answers then it's like what's
the point it's a worthwhile fan theory
if a question is set up and there is an
answer out there and then there's fan
theories that are trying to guess what
the answer is but it's less effective
when you know the filmmaker behind it
doesn't even know the answer himself so
it's snoke's death I feel like it would
have been cool to know more about Snoke
it would have been interesting to know a
little bit more about who Snoke is that
would have been neat I would have liked
that but to me learning about Snoke spaz
is not something that I feel is entirely
essential to it I love how Snoke is
using this film to support kylo
storyline because that's the effect of
smoking here is the effect it has on
kylo how he's becoming the ultimate
baddie when you watch The Force awakens
it looks like they're building Snoke up
to be the ultimate baddie
kyles kind of like second in charge so
maybe he'll be good in the end who knows
so when you kill off Snoke that's how
you surprise the audience I think if you
revealed smokes past it wouldn't have
felt like a surprise the surprise comes
in is that Snoke gets killed in a pretty
sweet way some people complain about how
snow couldn't tell the lightsaber was
moving
that doesn't bother me at all I still
think it was a really great moment and
that is a moment of surprise and it adds
to the main character which is kylo
snoke's not the main character using him
as a support to elevate the fear and
threat level of kylo Ren I find a much
more powerful voice than revealing
snoke's backstory and Rey's parents a
lot of the same things can be said
learning that Rey's parents were nobody
important I think is incredibly
effective for Daisy Ridley's character
Rey because that's what I felt was not
oh I want some cool fan theories
answered when Rey learns that where
she's coming to terms that because you
could tell she kind of knew that all
along but when she's coming in terms of
that that's very heartbreaking for her
to know that they didn't care about her
that they just trade her off like she
was nothing and I feel like that
storyline adds more effect that you
don't need to be a Skywalker you don't
need to have meta chlorines in order to
be someone special that you can be a
nobody or just a regular person and be
able to have that so I don't feel what
makes Rey special hinges on who her
parents are
that's why it doesn't bother me here's
what I'll say though what will bother me
well will really bother me especially
since regaining JJ back for episode 9 a
guy who's known to not give you answers
or give you answers that are satisfying
you got to explain in some way how Rey
is so good at what she does I like the
idea that the force is not exclusive to
Jedi alone and not exclusive to a
certain select for you but you have to
explain why ray is so hone in on the
force why she can fight pretty much
anybody because if you can explain that
in episode 9 you could do that without
honing in on who Ray's parents are you
can find some other way to do it the
thing is it needs to be answered it has
to be answered I'm not upset that we
don't get that answer in this one I'll
be upset that if by the conclusion of
this new trilogy we don't get an answer
because in force awakens
you know she flies the Millennium Falcon
like it's nothing she's able to force
mine manipulate a stormtrooper she takes
on kylo Ren and in this movie she fights
snoke's most worthy guards his best
trained got the ones he has in his
to guard him in case he snow can't
handle themselves she's able to fight
them because yes she works with kylo to
fight some of them but there's plenty of
moments in that cool ass fight where Rey
is off on her own fighting some of the
guards and killing them I need to have
at least something to know okay this is
why she's a little more special than
everybody else you need to have that in
this next installment that's for sure I
guess the last thing would be Luke dying
a lot of people seem pretty upset by
that some people question why he
actually didn't show up to go fight kylo
in person that it would have had the
same effect or something along those
lines I think Rian Johnson did it that
way have the effect be when kylo strikes
Luke and then he realizes oh he's just
pretty he's just a projection
communicating to us that Luke is back in
tune with the force is a much bigger
impact than him fighting again because
he one-point fights with Rey for like
ten seconds so his still fight he'll
still train so he could show up and
fight kylo but that doesn't necessarily
mean he's back in tune with using the
force it doesn't necessarily mean he's
honed in again on that peaceful light
side of the force but he says that line
to kylo I'll see you around kid I think
that adds more to the themes and the
messages that Rian Johnson was conveying
in this film love light honing in on the
force with those feelings are the key to
victory and that was the effect I felt
of why I thought it was so powerful when
he's up against kylo Ren but he's just a
projection cuz that's powerful for Rey
cuz she can feel it
Leia can know it and the thing is if
Luke showed up in person he might have
actually died I think because this
projection goes away people will know he
wasn't really there but it's not
confirmation for the whole that Luke is
actually dead ray says at one point but
she needs a teacher or a guide something
like that but the galaxy needs the
legend and when he does something like
that with that much force power that
allows the galaxy to feel like there is
hope because it's the great legendary
Luke Skywalker strictly using the force
and showing its full capability in the
end the second time viewing it I was
able to see a little bit more of the
problems specifically the Finn Rose in
post storyline there I was able to see
more of the issues with it everything
else that I loved about it or liked
about it I felt even strong
about I know when I first watched it I
said it was my favorite Star Wars movie
I watched a second time I'd say Empire
still my favorite and this is probably
my second favorite no that's not gonna
fly about a well with a lot of people
but that's just my personal ranking on
alright guys well feel free to comment
below leave the love and hate in the
comment boxes it's all engagement
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell please download and
follow us on the stardust app trying to
get to 2300 followers as soon as
possible and become a patron ejected a
it's like a second youtube channel trust
me on that